SHORTHANDED.
AND -- BACK
SAVED BY ANDERSON. ON -- NOT A
SHSHTHAN DAHLEN.
RYAN MERKLEY MIGHT JUST HAVE
HIS FIRST NHL GOAL.
IT IS HIS S BE A
GOAL.
I THINK IT WENT RIGHT OFF OF
BJORK.
GOOD JOB HERE.
HUNGRY.
LOOK AT HIM.
HE IS UP FRONT.
FINDS HERTL.
HERTL.
PRO LEVEL.
TAKES SOME TIME FOR DEFENSEMEN.
GIRGENSONS STOLEN. FENSE.
>> John: LOOSE.
SWATTED AWAY.
REALLY OPEPE
THE CROSSBAR.
THAT S
SCORING -- TWO GOALS.  COZENS L
IN FRONT.
SAVED
ULCERS FRAME.
THEY HAVE GOT ROOM.
YOU HAVE NUMBERS.
HERTL.
WATCH OUOUIT OUT.
BAR DOWN.
HANDS UP.
AN ABSOLUTE E
THIS MIGHT GIVE US A BETTER
LOOK.
THEIR  HEAD COACH.
DON'T HAVE HIM AGAIN TONIGHT.
DON'T HAVE
MARIO FERRARO. DONE IT.
THEY HAVE WON BATTLES.
SPAWNED ASPLUND.T THERE.
TERRIFIC -- RECOGNIZED START --
THE PRICE KEEPS GOING UP.
WHAT A GAME FORA GREAT JOB OF
WINNING THAT PUCK.
AND THEN HERTL TAKES OVER. RE C
HIS FIRST NHL GOAL.
LOOKING FOR
COUTURE ALMOST HAD ONE.
THE PAST FROM DAHLIN.
HE TRIED TO RETURN
OFF THE BACK OF REIMER -- JEFF
>> John: THEY NEED HIM.
>> Brian: THEY NEED